how's it going bros my name is Pippa
welcome back to heart of darkness here
we go
gonna shoot this [ __ ] right in the face
eat a dick you piece of trash you suck
all right hopefully will be easy oh god
this game is never easier hey
you're a dick this is one of the hardest
games I have ever played okay now we got
to shoot this guy in the ass while we go
up here that was an easy screen hey
let's do that again
more easy screens please can we shoot
him eat a dick Oh God
great I think we have to be able to get
out of this area soon
this [ __ ] waterpark and suck my day
okay all right let's be more gentle
paratis that mist that's great and I get
in okay we got to be fast and you know
what you can stuck my balls up your
mouth thank you thank you everyone I
want to say thanks to I think we did it
oh god we got these [ __ ] oh god no no
no no no [ __ ] them shoot them who needs
a laser gun would you god no now they're
back to back get away get away get away
now you're a grey you're greater in the
brain now fairness
thank you we did it whoa on fire baby we
are on fire I am literally burning ad
can we can we add like a burning dot m
WM dot mob burning effect cut mob
it sounds like I'm slapping the booty
when I do it I like it I like hey hey
hey guys what's up [ __ ] off [ __ ] off
[ __ ] off [ __ ] off [ __ ] off [ __ ] off [ __ ]
off oh my god there's a lot of them
Jesus Christ I hate them I'm just gonna
go I'm just gonna shake shake shake
Oh God Oh Oh God we [ __ ] up oh hey
how's it going good to go this way
I know this way I know this way oh no
I'm just gonna go this way [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you [ __ ] you y'all can suck my [ __ ]
green balls yeah oh god it never ends
it never ends does it y'all can [ __ ] off
and I get eaten get even
what about the total def count of this
[ __ ] game in
go go go go go climb those vines baby
why does a nose doing oh god there's so
many oh my god this is so crazy what the
[ __ ] am I supposed to do there stop
dodging my fireballs
[ __ ] take all of my [ __ ] they're
gonna come from behind soon no damn it
god damn and we're so close this is
ridiculous okay okay we're clear we're
clear
go go go go go go go go go go come on
baby come on yeah Wow Oh better fit at
better Peppa Baba oh my god
oh my god yes
Georgian pings
I love Jar Jar Binks
it's just the best don't you agree
how did you know it was upside down that
could have been down set
later did it find out jar-jar binks
wanted to get him to bed
and [ __ ] him that wasn't so happy jar
jar binks have duck penises their corks
kurz so they can drill right up there
it's true look it up George Lucas was
right
this is awkward to you this is making me
weird I don't know how you made it this
long is he wearing underpants it's
speaking Spanish speaking Spanish all
right
like the cutscenes in this game are the
crazy
holy [ __ ] that's that's pretty cool
and I felt like a giant orgy it's about
that how did these species make it this
far I don't know
space rekt whiskey
think is little too young stack your
whistle
he's gonna get high yep Wow Wow
game Wow oh that smoke or [ __ ] his
lungs pretty pretty accurate rule 34 on
that [ __ ] magic dark forces never come
it's a tic-tac-toe me voodoo magic don't
wait um Joe says evil bows never come
here
this animation probably cost a fortune
to make back in the neck
oh they're here awesome
I am so sick of dark forces she cut they
kind of look like a Marge Simpson ill
abate oh all right
why don't you shoot him with your ball
power you know the power that you had
why don't you use that no I don't see a
port next will never match
now they just oh whoa whoa I did not
expect him to get [ __ ] this is awesome
I mean this is horrible
this is great I mean I don't know what I
feel about it maybe I don't know yet
please insert heart of darkness disc two
press Start button to continue
oh that's good
oh it's a trip to the past this game
it's a trip to the past
oh wait okay so now start to continue it
should work how do they do this back in
the day I don't even know technology oh
here we are
okay we're hi guys uh oh that's probably
gonna kill me
thanks for that no thanks no thanks uh
how would some house that no thanks you
and I turn into [ __ ] flames okay they
die fairly easily it's so much ah oh my
god I became a [ __ ] converse shoe
and another one god damn it I oh my god
what did he see that action in the
background that was [ __ ] sweet man
listen Oh God let's focus on get the air
ones I think there's a real problem here
but they keep coming down so oh my god
this is insane if Zane from one
direction was I guess he's not in one
direction it oh hey hey oh my god what
happened
what the [ __ ] way oh my god hey this
game is really something else isn't it
and I turn into a shoe again and we
watched a shoot all thanks for that game
all right we gotta go down we gotta go
down we gotta go down to funky town
alright where do we go this way yep
nailed it nailed it nailed it thank you
thank you game thank you came doing
better those so [ __ ] cool this game
they need to make a remake I love it I
love it okay we're going down no all
right we're going right
probably I'm really glad I'm not live
streaming it makes it a lot Oh God not
the [ __ ] maggot it's disgusting
Oh got him got him got him got him got
him oh my god you got to be fast another
one whoo there it is so much time it
took me better to just realize you have
to hold down a oh that's gonna be more I
know it oh my god what do I do
yeah boy yes son
all right we got an a-list em come on
brush do you think I can do it yep
whoa and you're dead nay fun oh my god
[ __ ] you don't Yahoo me [ __ ] go [ __ ]
yourself have you thought about that die
die die die die just die die die no
matter what
alright gonna go this way now don't you
dare [ __ ] kill me
we're probably gonna move that but I
just want to check out the situation
alright this looks like a nice place
isn't it what's up there let's check out
here first all right what do we got up
here no man for a fix down spot Allah no
I don't like that what just happened
what is up with that
maybe it's search the shadow we know and
we need to put it somewhere else all
right
it's the shadow still there no it's not
hey we did it can we reach though huh
awesome hey I'm getting better
finally ah
uh sucker my ass who's causing the
shadow you are another one another one
okay we can pass but we gotta be fast
okay we're good
okay I'm not trusting these trees never
trust trees that's a woman our mom my
mom always said never trust tree it was
a wise man um hey guys we just got to be
faster well then that was that thing hey
I'm fine I'm fine everybody I'm fine
look at me I'm dancing yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah okay we're fine let's go back
up can I go here okay we're fine you
just got a win win win no matter what
Oh God that does not look good all right
Oh God any [ __ ] me right in the ass
what a [ __ ] mess well then back to
beginning is that tree gonna touch me Oh
God they are everywhere I'm just gonna
shoot left to right and up and down and
up and down and moving out around Oh God
hey don't touch me [ __ ] no what
did I [ __ ] tell you don't die I'm
fine my legs are made of steel man never
don't hit oh my god he pushed me down
and then oh my god got him oh god oh my
god [ __ ] minier there ah got him got
him yeah y'all come out idiots without
all of them I think that was all of them
alright mr. tree you play by the rules
oh god it was not all of them ma ma ma
Oh
aah
they never instead okay we're fine I
think I think we're fine please mom Oh
Oh the stakes are high come out come out
daddy's want to play that is one Danny
wanna play good [ __ ] suck my ass
alright we're not dying now we didn't
come this far to die now
all right are they trapped in there
what's going on can I shoot or other
trap okay so am i I suppose if can go
here and I can shoot this no I cannot I
I can't go down there okay what if I go
up oh my god I hate the worms oh my god
no [ __ ] me [ __ ] you [ __ ] up [ __ ] up not
on the ground [ __ ] [ __ ] got him
alright alright here we go
[ __ ] all of y'all
peace out was I supposed to do that
was I supposed to do that because I sure
as hell didn't do it on purpose is that
not what I'm supposed to do shoot it I
guess I'm supposed to take the thing a
shoot here shoot her here you're getting
dangerously close to me tree and I don't
like it stop I have no choice but to go
oh oh oh my god oh my god was I supposed
to do that oh god they're all coming
they're all coming all the George Lucas
is ah stop it
keep shooting oh did I do that right or
did I do that wrong or did I do it at
all cuz I don't [ __ ] know Jesus Christ
I'm just gonna shuffle kid touch this
vide Diddy diddy did it can't touch it P
na dhih dhih dhih dhih dhih teacher what
do I do
[ __ ] supposed to fall off that's the
dumbest thing alright so now we're just
grab it right awesome awesome awesome oh
it's awesome awesome awesome awesome
just awesome Oh Lord it was not nice to
me Lord was not nice to me Lord did not
forgive my sins you can't hit me
ah oh there's one more that son of a
[ __ ] try to [ __ ] me the tried out a
[ __ ]
the son of a [ __ ] tried to [ __ ] me huh
son of a [ __ ] try to [ __ ] me what son
of a [ __ ] tried to [ __ ] me what son of
a [ __ ] try to [ __ ] what you can't [ __ ]
a duck and let you try you can [ __ ] a
duck unless you don't you can't [ __ ] a
truck unless you truck a truck every day
and every day and night rock that truck
[ __ ] a truck [ __ ] a flag like a truck
mate stop doing that you're being super
annoying
alright you know what you know what
there comes a time where you kill
yourself no oh god please no please god
please be lord forgive my sins I will
quit YouTube
I'm sorry Satan I did it wrong but god
damn it are you kidding me don't you
[ __ ] touch a man that did not ask to
be [ __ ] we can still do it we can still
do it we can still do it we can still do
it we can still do it we can still do it
we can still do it we could still yes oh
my craft
not this one's for you I love you let's
let's let's let's go to on a date and
don't tell my dear
okay what do I do now knotch honestly I
didn't think this through what do I do I
let them all out but like what do I do
now do I go up here thanks notch you're
the best you don't how it hit me right
in the [ __ ] face notch why didn't you
tell me about the boulder if I stole
thank God
oh thank god I would have [ __ ] you oh
that came out wrong now all right well
[ __ ] me I'll just go this way ha ha ha
ha oh that's good I'm just chilling here
hey how's that how's that for a [ __ ]
change stop it all right there's a Ledge
there but I'm just gonna go up ok so
they hit the ground dicks oh my god oh
my god oh my god I'm a faun oh I wasn't
even that hard what the [ __ ] is my
problem
hey hey who's the tough guy now we'll
burn it out oh that felt good that felt
real nice I felt like the first time I
had him a damn happy meal oh god what
that [ __ ] crabs really crabs really
craps
really oh my oh my god oh my god oh my
god
all right what do I do with the [ __ ]
crabs what do I do about the [ __ ]
crabs what do I do about the [ __ ]
crabs I crabs
oh my god ah
what are you doing me
haha
kill me do it do it now please click the
button you know what I'm talking about
click it
alright press thank you for watching
this video really appreciate it
next one is right there but before you
go go ahead and leave it like and I'll
see you bros in the next one
stay awesome Oh looking at me okay don't
take it all in buckle boys I know I look
good